Male rape is one of the most stigmatised and silenced traumas in our society. Too many survivors are left believing there alone, when in fact their pain might be tragically more common than most of us might realise. In this episode, I'm joined by Connor to break that silence. Together we'll talk about the realities of male rape, why consent and shame matter so deeply, and what we can all do to better support survivors. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist and if you'd like to understand to support or to heal, you're in the right place. Please like, subscribe, comment and share so this vital
男性强奸是我们社会中最受污名化和最被噤声的创伤之一。太多的幸存者认为自己孤身一人，而事实上，他们的痛苦可能比我们大多数人意识到的更为普遍。在这一集中，康纳（Connor）和我一起打破了这种沉默。我们将共同探讨男性强奸的现实、为什么同意和羞耻感如此重要，以及我们所有人能做些什么来更好地支持幸存者。我是玛丽安（Marianne）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。如果您想了解如何提供支持或进行疗愈，那么您来对地方了。请点赞、订阅、评论并分享，让这一至关重要的
conversation can reach more people. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist and I'm joined here today by a fellow podcaster actually. Connor Whiteley, welcome along. Hi, I'm Marion and I thank you for life having me. So I'm a clinical psychology master's student and I'm also the host of the Psychology World Podcast and I'm really looking forward to getting into our conversation today. Me too. But I think before we do, if we just do a little bit of kind of safety and housekeeping, obviously with the nature of our topic today, if someone is listening or watching and there's young ears around, I think probably now is not the most appropriate time for them to
对话能够触及更多人。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是另一位播客主持人，康纳·怀特利（Connor Whiteley），欢迎你。嗨，玛丽安，谢谢你邀请我。我是一名临床心理学硕士生，也是《心理学世界》（Psychology World）播客的主持人，我非常期待今天能深入探讨我们的对话。我也是。但在我们开始之前，我想我们先进行一些安全和注意事项的说明。显然，鉴于我们今天话题的性质，如果有人正在收听或观看，且周围有年幼的孩子，我想现在可能不是让他们
engage with this episode. If you're in a car and you've got kids in the car, I think this is one to come back to. Maybe skip along to the next episode or the most, the previous one, choose this one a little bit later because it is a big topic. It does matter. It's really important. But we do have to do a little bit of a trigger warning that because we're talking about sexual violence, if maybe somebody even is not feeling strong enough to engage with the content themselves right now, we can absolutely give them permission to come back to this later or maybe skip this one altogether, can't we, Connor? Yeah, definitely, though, because this is a really hard topic and at the end of the day, we just want you to be like over okay and protect
参与本集内容的最佳时机。如果您在车里，且车上有孩子，我想这一集最好留到以后再听。也许可以跳过这一集，听下一集或上一集，稍后再选择这一集，因为它是一个沉重的话题。它确实很重要，非常重要。但我们必须发出一点触发警告，因为我们正在讨论性暴力，如果有人觉得现在自己没有足够强大的心理承受能力来接触这些内容，我们完全允许他们以后再回来听，或者干脆跳过这一集，对吧，康纳？是的，绝对是这样，因为这是一个非常沉重的话题，归根结底，我们只是希望你一切安好，并保护
your own mental health. Yeah, absolutely. So can we talk a little bit about male sexual violence and how prevalent that is? Because some people might live in this. where they think that that's not a thing or that that's certainly not happening maybe in the UK. Could you talk to us a little bit about that, Connor? Yeah, definitely. So before I was raped, like in, yes, yep, like in April, 20 or 24, I also thought that it doesn't happen that often. Women are the only people who tend to get raped and they tend to suffer like a sexual violence. But as I was researching it more, because my own mental health was starting to deterior, I realised this is actually like a lot more
你自己的心理健康。是的，绝对是。那么，我们能谈谈男性性暴力及其普遍性吗？因为有些人可能生活在一种环境中，认为这不是一回事，或者认为这肯定不会在英国发生。康纳，你能跟我们谈谈这一点吗？是的，当然。在我被强奸之前，比如在2024年4月，我也认为这种情况并不常发生。人们往往认为只有女性会被强奸，她们往往是性暴力的受害者。但随着我深入研究，因为我自己的心理健康开始恶化，我意识到这实际上要普遍得多。
common. So some of the statistics that I found, but especially when it comes to like university students, is about 13% of all university students will experience some form of like sexual violence. When we focus on like a postgrad student, 2.5% of a male students will egg experience at sexual violence in their time at the university. But if we look at undergrad students, this actually increases to 6.8%. And the reason why this is in Portland, even though with this just sounds like single-digit figures, is that if we think about the hundreds of thousands of people that go to university across the Western world, this is still tens upon tens of thousands of different students. So, but this is a massive issue, especially when we start to think about
所以我发现了一些统计数据，特别是在大学生群体中，大约13%的大学生会经历某种形式的性暴力。当我们关注研究生时，2.5%的男性学生在大学期间会经历性暴力。但如果我们看本科生，这个比例实际上增加到了6.8%。之所以提到这一点很重要，是因为即使这听起来只是个位数的数字，但如果我们考虑到西方世界有成千上万的人上大学，这仍然意味着成千上万名不同的学生。所以，这是一个巨大的问题，特别是当我们开始思考
the stark negative mental health implications, like the oppression and anxiety, post-traumatic stress disorder, amongst other mental health difficulties. Yeah, and it's just, you know, the trauma of it. this might involve physical trauma, but certainly the psychological fallout of this as well. And I'm sorry to hear of your experiences and thank you for pitching this episode to me. It's really important and I hope that it feels okay for you to discuss this. It was a topic I'd first become aware of when I was at university actually. And I was a big fan at the time of a Channel 4 show called Hollyoaks. And at the time there was a character called Luke and he ended up being raped and it was shocking and violent and it really led to that character exploring and experiencing, you know, so many different things.
其带来的严重负面心理健康影响时，比如抑郁和焦虑、创伤后应激障碍，以及其他心理健康困难。是的，而且你知道，这种创伤……这可能涉及身体创伤，但肯定还有随之而来的心理后果。听到你的经历我很难过，也谢谢你向我提议这一集。这真的很重要，我希望你讨论这些话题时感觉还好。我第一次意识到这个话题是在上大学的时候。当时我是第四频道（Channel 4）节目《圣橡镇少年》（Hollyoaks）的忠实粉丝。当时有一个叫卢克（Luke）的角色，他最终被强奸了，这令人震惊且暴力，它确实导致那个角色探索并经历了许多不同的事情。
You know, he was in a relationship with some, with a female at the time and it led to him changing in that relationship and changing how outgoing and confident he was. and, you know, the shame and the blame and the guilt. This really can affect people on all levels, can't it, Connor? Yeah, definitely. And the thing that I found so surprising was after what happened to me, was that there's not a single area of your life that isn't affected from an example. Like, I also used to be really out there, yes, like outgoing, confident. I could like go into like any rumor.
你知道，他当时正在和一位女性谈恋爱，这导致他在那段关系中发生了改变，也改变了他原本外向和自信的状态。而且，你知道，那种羞耻感、责备感和内疚感。这真的会影响各个层面的人，对吧，康纳？是的，绝对是。我发现最令人惊讶的事情是，在我经历那件事之后，我发现你生活中没有一个领域是不受影响的。比如，我过去也曾非常外向、自信。我可以走进任何房间。
and I'm also all autistic. So yes, I needed to be like a bit performative to be extradited at times. So I could do that and I was happy. But after I was raped, my Angazia T-Ped and I could like go out. But at the end of the day, because I was so fearful that I would get rape day again,
而且我还是个自闭症患者。所以是的，我有时需要表现得有点表演性才能显得外向。所以我能做到，而且我很开心。但在我被强奸后，我的焦虑加剧了，我虽然还能出门，但归根结底，因为我非常害怕再次被强奸，
it would just be a like real struggle. And I would end up having like a panic attacks and just a like mental breakdown as soon as I got home. But it's also interesting that you should mention like Holyoaks because after you mentioned it in our emails, like Google did. And it's absolutely brilliant that it's getting that representation. But it does feed into some quite problematic myths about male or sexual violence and, to be on, like, sexual violence as a whole,
这变成了一种真正的挣扎。我一回到家就会出现恐慌发作，甚至精神崩溃。但有趣的是，你提到了《圣橡镇少年》，因为你在邮件中提到它之后，我用谷歌搜索了一下。它能获得这种呈现是非常棒的。但它确实助长了一些关于男性性暴力，甚至关于性暴力整体的相当成问题的神话，
because there's this big idea that when you're raped, you're fighting, you're screaming, you're kicking, you're punching. And this myth goes for females and male were survivors. But in a reality, the vast majority of a people don't fight, punch and, like, kick their way out of some people. And this is not a good way at, like, a phrase is simply let it happen. But in a reality, it's the fawn response. So you've got the fight, flight, and the fawn response, where you were just like freeze that up because, yes, and like, this is what happens to about, like, 90% of our survivors, including my, well, my self, though. So it's good that we've got this media representation that's raising aware.
因为有一种巨大的观念认为，当你被强奸时，你会反抗、尖叫、踢打、挥拳。这种神话适用于女性和男性幸存者。但实际上，绝大多数人并没有通过打斗、挥拳和踢打来摆脱对方。这并不是说他们只是“任由其发生”。但实际上，这是一种“讨好反应”（fawn response）。你有战斗、逃跑和讨好反应，你会像那样僵住，因为是的，大约90%的幸存者都会发生这种情况，包括我自己。所以，有这种媒体呈现来提高意识是好事，
but it doesn't have to be afflict about what happens in reality. I'm with you, yeah. And thank you for helping make that distinction for us, that actually what we're looking at is it's a lack of consent, actually. And it doesn't always mean, you know, physical violence or restraint. But it's, I really think that the powerful video by Thames Valley Police it's called T and Consent, and I would urge anybody, urge anybody, whatever reason you're watching this podcast for, I would urge anybody to check that
但它并不一定能反映现实中发生的事情。我同意你的看法。谢谢你帮我们做出这种区分，即我们实际上关注的是缺乏同意。这并不总是意味着身体暴力或束缚。但我真的认为泰晤士河谷警方制作的那个名为《茶与同意》（Tea and Consent）的视频非常有力，我强烈建议任何人，无论你出于什么原因观看这个播客，我都强烈建议任何人去
out on YouTube. I will link that in the show notes and in the description. It's so important that actually we are really being clear about explicitly, about a consent. It's so important. And actually, even if halfway through whatever's happening, maybe you consent it to begin with, but then you change your mind and you don't want to do that anymore. That's you withdrawing consent and that should be honoured and respected. So thank you for making that distinction, Connor. Yeah, like you're welcome. Welcome. But also building a upon the idea of con assent. Yes, like T is a really good video. But what I also learned, as I was re-covering, it was the idea of in a
YouTube上看看。我会把它放在节目说明和描述中。我们真正明确地界定“同意”是非常重要的。这太重要了。而且，即使在事情进行到一半时，也许你一开始同意了，但后来你改变了主意，不想再继续了。那就是你撤回了同意，这应该得到尊重。所以谢谢你做出这种区分，康纳。是的，不客气。但也要在“同意”的概念上进行延伸。是的，《茶》是一个非常好的视频。但我在康复过程中学到的另一件事是“热情同意”（enthusiastic consent）的概念，因为有时你可能只是出于恐惧而说“是”。那不是同意。那是你因为害怕如果你说“不”，对方会伤害你，或者他们会做更糟的事情而说“是”。更糟的事情。这就是“热情同意”概念的由来。所以，如果你正在发生性行为，或者如果你正在进行某种性行为，那么重要的是，当你的伴侣说“是”时，他们是真的想做，他们是热情的，他们是兴奋的。
enthusiastic connessent because like sometimes you might just say yes out of fear. So that's and that is not con assent. That is you saying yes because you're scared about what if you say no, will the other person hurt you? What will they do with something even worse? Even worse. This is where the idea of in a fusciastic concessant comes in, though. So like if you're having sex or if you're doing a, well, if you're doing a like a sexual act, then it's important that when your partner says yes, they're actually really want to do it, they're in a fusiastic, they're excited, excited.
所以这是另一个重要的区分。确实如此。而且，它实际上进入了“强制控制”的范畴，几个月前我和克丽丝·罗伯茨（Chrissy Roberts）做过一期非常强有力的节目。我们确实想确保双方都愿意参与，都同意这样做，并且都能控制事情何时发生以及何时不发生。是的，这又是一个非常重要的观点。我知道在过去几年里，《驯鹿宝贝》（Baby Reindeer）在Netflix上引起了轰动。那里面也有关于男性强奸的情节，对吧，康纳？是的，绝对是。我没能看那个，因为这不应该让任何人感到惊讶，但在你被强奸后，你实际上无法观看任何带有性参考和性触发因素的内容。但今天早上，我确实快速谷歌了一下。我听说它真的很好。但我喜欢的一点是，它确实表明女性也可能是性掠夺者和性暴力的施暴者，因为这是社会中另一个巨大的神话，
So that's another in appalling the extinction. It really is. And actually, yeah, it kind of enters into kind of coercive control, which is a really, really powerful episode I did with Chrissy Roberts a few months ago. And really, you know, we want to make sure that both parties want to be there, are consenting to that and are in control of when it happens and when it doesn't happen. Yeah, so again, a really important, a really important point. And I know in the last few years, baby reindeer was a viral Netflix sensation. And that had a storyline around male rape as well, didn't it, Connor? Yeah, definitely. So I wasn't able to like see that because, yeah, because this shouldn't be a like surprise to anyone. But after you've been, right, you actually can't watch anything with any of like references at like sex and like sexual triggers. But this morning, I did do a quick like a Google. And I have heard that it's like really a good. But the thing. that I like about this is that it does show that women that can also be sexual predators and perpetrators of like sexual violence because that's another like a massive myth in
因为每当我们想到“受害者”——我认为这是一个对经历过性暴力的人来说非常剥夺权力的负面词汇——是的，当我们想到受害者时，我们总是倾向于认为他们是女性，而“受害者”这个词有一些非常负面的含义，因为它暗示你软弱、破碎、一团糟，这对于作为有抱负的心理学家来说是没有帮助的。作为我们工作的一部分，在支持那些
society because whenever we tend to think about victim which I think is very disenpowering negative term for someone who's actually gone through a sexual violence yeah so like when we think about victims we always tend to think of them as like women and the term a victim has some very negative connotations because it implies that you're weak, you're broken, you're messed up, which is not helpful as aspiring site ecologists. And as a part of our job, when it comes to, like, supporting those
经历过性创伤的人时，那种赋权感和自信心非常重要。然后当我们想到“施暴者”这个词时，由于社会中的神话，我们倾向于认为只有男性才会是施暴者。
who have been through sexual trauma, is that sense of empowerment, again, and that self-confidence. Confidence at all. And then when we think about the term perpetrator, because of the myths in a society, we tend to think that it's exclusive males who reckon that be perpetrators.
所以这就是为什么像《驯鹿宝贝》这样的节目非常有用，因为它有助于打破那些刻板印象和神话。是的，没错。我想有一个时刻她似乎……我想她猥亵了他。是的，但我认为其中的男性性暴力实际上是男对男。但我完全理解为什么这不是你会主动去寻找的内容。我完全理解这一点。
So that's why programs like baby a reindeer are really a useful, because it helps to affect those stereotypes and those myths. Yeah, exactly. I think there was a moment where she kind of, I think she groped him. And yeah, but I think the male sexual violence was actually male to male in that. But I could absolutely understand why that's not something that you're going to seek out. I absolutely understand that.
好的。我想我们还想打破另一个神话，那就是关于勃起，以及它可能暗示或不暗示某人的状态，无论他们是否同意，是否准备好，是否想要。关于这一点，康纳，你有什么想说的吗？是的，当我提到这一点时，我记得我和我的一些朋友有过这样的对话。
Okay. And I think another myth we want to bust as well is, is about erections. and what that might say or not say about someone, whether they're consenting, whether they're up for it, whether they want it. What would you have to say about that, Conor? Yeah, so when I would say, like, to your nature, I remember this, like, conversation with some of my friends.
他们基本上转过身来说，哦，这意味着我不可能被强奸，因为如果他们勃起了，那他们就是想要的。当时，我觉得那肯定不对，但我没有反驳，因为我当时很年轻，他们是我的朋友。但在我经历那件事之后，因为你确实会勃起，因为这是一个你无法控制的生理过程。
And so they did basically turn around and say that, oh, well, I meant that I can't be evaded because if they get an eviction, then they want it. And at the time, I was like, that can't be right, but I didn't challenge it. because I was young and they were my friends. But then after what happened to me, like, because you do get an eviction, because it's a physiological process which you can't control.
这仅仅是一个生物学过程，无论你是否真的感到性兴奋，它都会发生。这让你非常困惑。它让你质疑，哦等等，我享受那个过程了吗？我是自找的吗？它引出了这么多令人非常痛苦的问题，
It is simply a biological process that will happen, or whether you're actually sexually aroused or not. It makes you really confuse. It makes you a question, oh wait, did I enjoy that? Was I asking for that? And it brings up so many of these really distressing questions,
当你把这些与社会中关于男性性暴力的其他神话以及缺乏相关讨论结合起来时，这真的非常困难，只会加剧你的创伤。但回答你的问题，我只想说，勃起甚至射精并不意味着你在享受。这并不意味着你在同意。这仅仅是一个无论情况如何都会发生的生物学过程。是的。我认为这是一个非常有力的信息。而且我知道从我的临床工作经验来看，强奸在战争中被用来对付各种性别的人，作为一种暴力行为，旨在从心理上摧毁人们，摧毁他们的精神。
which when you combine or with other myths about in a society and the lack of conversation around male sexual violence is really difficult and it only compounds your trauma. But to answer your question, I would just say that a election and even ejaculation is, it does not mean that you're in adjoining. It does not mean that you're consenting. It is simply a biological process which will happen whatever the case. Yeah. And I think that's a really powerful message to make, actually. And I know from my experiences of working clinically that often rape is used against people of every gender in war and as a way of kind of an act of violence and to kind of break people psychologically and break their spirit in
所以我经常与那些因成为政治犯或仅仅作为军事政变的一部分而被强奸的人一起工作，无论是什么情况，人们进来时，随之而来的故事都是可怕的。能做这项工作是一种真正的荣幸。但实际上，当我与处于那种情况下的男性一起工作时，他们可能从未告诉过任何人，他们可能已经接受了多年的心理健康治疗。你知道，他们可能与移民部门进行了大量的沟通，寻求庇护，很多人问过他们问题，但他们从未感到能够分享这些。
war. So I've often worked with people who have been raped as a result of being a political prisoner or kind of just as a part of kind of, you know, military coups or, you know, whatever, like people have come in and, you know, the stories come with, you know, the men they came, they came to the village and then the stories there, therefore, that unfold are horrendous. A real privilege to do that work. But actually, when I've worked with men in that situation, they have maybe never told anybody and they might have had years of mental health work. You know, they might have had lots and lots of work with immigration and kind of seeking asylum and lots of people asking questions, but I've never felt able to share that.
然后只有当他们在我的治疗室里时，我才帮助他们弥合差距，将点滴联系起来。我有时甚至会给他们讲故事，实际上有些人经历过这样的情况，可能发生过类似的事情。他们起初几乎无法面对。但我们不断努力，不断努力，然后他们能够经历一个非常重要的“去羞耻化”过程。我能够帮助进行心理教育，就像你做的那样。
And then it's only when they're in my therapy room that actually I help them to bridge the gaps and join the dots. And I almost tell them stories actually sometimes people who've been to situations like this have had maybe things like this have happened to them. And they almost can't go there straight away. But we work and we work and we work. and then they're able to have a really important process of being deshamed. And I'm able to help do that psychoeducation, exactly like you did, really.
我们说，实际上，有时当阴茎被触碰时，它会变硬。有时如果触碰得足够热情，高潮和射精就会发生。有时人们会对自己的身体做出这种反应感到非常羞耻，因为它给了他们混合的信息：我享受那个过程了吗？因为那是享受的终极标志，但不是，你知道，你并没有同意让那种事情发生。这只是身体的自然反应。女性也会发生同样的事情，你知道，当阴蒂被触碰时，它也会有反应，即使这不是你同意的事情，它也会感觉很好。所以我真的想打开并强化这种叙事，即有人甚至可能会说，
We're saying, actually, sometimes when a penis is touched, it will get harder. And sometimes if it's touched with enough, you know, enthusiasm, an orgasm, an ejaculation will happen. And sometimes people can have a lot of shame about their body doing that, because then it gives them mixed messages of did I enjoy that? because that's the ultimate sign of enjoyment, but no, you know, you didn't consent for that happen to happen. This is just, this is just what bodies do. And the same thing happens with females as well, you know, when a clitoris is touched, that can respond and it can, it can feel nice even though it's not something you're consenting to. So I really want to just, yeah, open up and reinforce and enforce that narrative that, you know, someone might even say,
“你享受了。你高潮了，不是吗？”那不是同意。那仍然是你不想要的事情。这些信息真的非常重要。是的，绝对是。谢谢你的分享，玛丽安。我很遗憾你的客户经历了这些，因为那太可怕了，我理解他们所经历的一切，但拥有这样一个开放的空间非常重要，所以我感谢你为你的客户提供这些。是的，绝对是。我们能思考一下，什么样的东西能帮助经历过这种暴力的人吗？你知道，是社区、友谊、家庭还是治疗？康纳，你认为什么样的东西能提供帮助？
well, you enjoyed it. You know, you came, didn't you? That is not consent. That is still something that is not wanted. Really, really important messages. Yeah, definitely. I thank you for sharing that, Mabia. And I'm really sorry that your clients went through that because that is just awful and I understand what they've been through but that's just like having that open a space is a really important so I thank you for providing that with your clients yeah absolutely can we think about you know what sort of things will help somebody who's been through been through violence like this you know is it is it community is it friendships is it family is it therapy what's your idea about the sort of things that can help Connor so I would say that
我认为有很多不同的因素可以提供帮助，但我认为有几个不同的领域对于强奸幸存者来说是至关重要的。就个人而言，最初会有一个巨大的否认期，至少在我的经历中是这样，因为在我经历那件事后的头两天，我心想：不，什么都没发生，我只是反应过度了，我的身体只是背叛了我，我不知道为什么我会恐慌发作，我睡眠困难，但你只是处于完全的否认状态。然后你可能会经历其他事情，除了创伤后应激障碍、抑郁
there's so many different factors that can help but i would say that there are like a few different areas which are flat out a critical threat like rape a saliva so in terms of the person them ourselves they're myself though so initially there will be a massive denial period period though at least in my egg experience because after what happened to me happened for the first two days i was like nope nothing's happened i'm just overreacting my body's just betraying me i don't know why i'm having these a panic attacks and i'm troubled um sleeping but you're just in complete denial and then something else that you might act like experience and besides the like post-traumatic stress disorder the depression
和其他负面心理健康症状外，你不想让自己感受到这些情绪，因为面对现实吧，这些情绪以及处理发生在你身上的事情是可怕的，非常令人痛苦。所以这会让事情变得非常困难。有时你会采取一些策略，要么让自己非常忙碌，这样你就不用去想这些情绪。我就是这么做的。你也会采取一些策略来麻痹这些情绪。我知道有些人觉得需要喝大量的酒，或者像我一样使用药物。是的，这些是适应不良的应对机制，我们需要寻求支持来打破这些。但幸存者只是
and the other negative mental health symptoms is that you don't want to allow yourself to fill with the emotions because let's face it the emotions and processing what happened to you is awful it's really distressing the stress network so that can make it really a difficult. So sometimes you in like gauging, like strategies to either keep yourself really busy so you don't have to think about the emotions. And that's what I did. You're also in engaging like strategies which help blunt the emotions. So I know that some people feel with the need to drink a lot of like alcohol or like I do with drugs. And yes, these are maladaptive coping mechanisms and we do need to see a port to like break these. But the saliva is just a,
在尽其所能地生存。为了生存。所以，知道寻求心理健康和心理治疗非常重要，因为治疗师能够帮助你处理创伤，并为你提供所需的技巧和策略，以改善你的生活，减轻你的心理压力，并将创伤整合到你的生活中。因为不幸的是，如果你经历过性创伤，你只会希望它消失。
it's just a doing everything that they possibly can to survive. life to survive though. So knowing that it's really in appalling that you do seek out mental health and psychological therapy because like a therapist will be able to like help you work you will help you work through with your trauma and also do with just like her give you with the like tips and the strategies are that you need to be able to like in approval your life deacres decrease your psychological de-a-stress and integrate the trauma into your life because unfortunately, and if you've experienced sexual trauma, you will just want it gone.
你永远不想拥有这段经历，你会很乐意在余生中忘记它。但不幸的是，创伤不是这样运作的，更健康的选择是——我开始在生活中越来越欣赏这个选择——你可以整合它。你处理它，它就像在后视镜里一样。它发生在你身上，但它不再控制你。如果你经历过性暴力，
You will never want to have this, and you would quite happily just forget it for the rest of your life. But unfortunately, let's not have trauma works and the healthier option. And the option that I'm really starting to appreciate more in my life is that you can just integrate it. You work through it, it's just like it's in the rear of the mirror. So it's happened to you, but it's no longer controlling you. And if you've been through a sexual violence,
那么我刚才说的话听起来绝对是不可能的，因为在我康复的七个月里，我以为我永远不会康复。我以为我永远不会进入一段关系等等。但通过与一位强奸专家咨询师合作，这真的很有帮助。此外，作为一名有抱负的临床心理学家，
then me just saying that sounds absolutely impossible because for the seven months it took me at a hill, I thought that I would never heal. I thought I would never get into a relationship, etc. But by working with a counsellor, who was a rape specialist, then that was really helpful. Also, as an aspiring clinical,
我知道躯体工作（somatic work），即与身体合作很重要。例如，在焦虑期间，关于焦虑感、手心出汗和身体感觉的心理教育，我知道这很重要。但只有在我的创伤工作之后，我才意识到，哦，我的身体是那个惊慌失措的东西，是处理器出了点问题，我的神经系统对大多数刺激反应过度。所以这就是
ecologist. I knew that asthmatic work, so working with body wasn't important. For example, during anxiety, the psychoeducation between like, um, in that, yes, against the feeling of anxiety and the like sweaty hands and the physical sensations. I knew that was important, but it was only after my trauma work that I realized, oh, my body is the thing that's a freaking out, It's the processor that's gone a bit at a wall, and my nervous system is overreacting to a most stimuli. So that's
为什么它非常有用，我学会了一些自我安抚技巧，比如“方块呼吸法”（Boxer breathing）。你吸气四秒，屏住呼吸四秒，然后呼气四秒，然后，是的，你不断重复，直到它激活你的副交感神经系统，让你感到平静。还有很多其他技巧我确实推荐。有一本很棒的书帮助了我，叫《性创伤疗愈工作手册》（Healing Sexual Trauma Workbook），作者是埃里卡·谢尔曼（Erica Sherman）。这就是我向个人推荐的一些技巧和窍门。谢谢。我会确保在描述和节目说明中链接到那本书。我很高兴你能克服这些。我也很高兴你能在七个月内做到这一点。这不是处方，每个人都有不同的时间框架，取决于获得服务的速度，
why it was really useful, whether I learned some of my self-soofing techniques like Boxer breathing. So you breathe in for four, you hoe for four, then you breathe out for four form, and then, yeah, and then like you keep at doing that until it activates your parasympathetic nervous
情况会有所不同，但请务必在感到有帮助时寻求心理健康支持。我想如果我不谈谈作为犯罪向警方报案，那将是我的失职。实际上，你可以在任何时候这样做，你可能104岁了，也可以说：“实际上，我想谈谈发生在我身上的那件事。”我认为通常媒体上有很多关于人们在唱诗班或有组织宗教中工作的事情，你知道，你可能在发生这种情况时更年轻。但这不对，这不对，这不对。所以，这可以作为犯罪报案，如果你当时有决心的话，确实应该这样做。但你可能也受了身体伤害。所以你可能需要去急诊室，
system and you feel a karma, though. And then like there's a lot of like other techniques that I really do recommend. And there's a brilliant book that helped me. It's called Healing a Sexual Trauma Worker Book by Everker, Sherman. So that's some of the tips and tricks that I would recommend an individual. Thank you. I'll make sure I link to that in the description and the show notes. I'm pleased that you've been able to work through that. And I'm pleased that actually you've been able to do that in seven months as well. That is not prescriptive everyone else will have a different time frame and depending on speed of access to
让他们照顾你可能甚至看不到的伤口，但实际上事情可能会非常痛苦。我们只是要确保你一切安好。他们当然会理解你会非常难过和痛苦，但他们会尽可能理智地照顾你，确保你的身体得到愈合所需的治疗。我知道这些是非常非常困难的对话，但我真的想尝试消除这个过程的羞耻感。这不是你的错，但
services that will be different but yeah please do reach out for mental health support if you feel that would be helpful and I guess it would be remiss of me to not talk about kind of reporting this as a crime to the police as well and that actually you know you can do that at any point you know you could be 104 and be like actually I would like to talk about this thing that happened to me And I think often, you know, there's been lots of things in the media about kind of people working in, you know, who's choir boys or, you know, as choristers and kind of organised religion and, you know, that actually you might have been younger when this happens as well. But it's, you know, it's not okay. It's not okay. It's not okay. So, yeah, this can be reported as a crime and actually should be if you feel like you've got the resolve for that at that time. but also you might have been physically injured. And so you might need to, you know, go to accident and an emergency
你的身体确实值得被治愈，最终你的心灵也值得再次愈合。是的，绝对是。书中最让我喜欢的一句话是：“这不是你的错，因为你无法阻止它。”当我读到那句话时，我想，哦哇，那真是太真实了。那真的很强大。是的，很强大。而且，在报案的想法上，值得庆幸的是，有更多的人站出来报告他们的性暴力。在新闻中，我们倾向于看到许多案件，值得庆幸的是，这些案件被判有罪。作为一名幸存者，我喜欢看到这一点。我真的为那些人感到高兴，因为它表明我们所有的幸存者都非常赋权、强大，我们都令人难以置信。但在我心理健康最糟糕的时候，那些新闻报道也让我哭泣和感到压力，因为我没有决定向警方报告我的袭击和强奸。我知道绝大多数人也没有这样做。我认为讨论这一点也很好，因为作为一名幸存者，你也会因为没有报告它而感到非常内疚。但这可以理解，而且没关系，因为作为有抱负的心理学家，
to help them care for any wounds that you might not even be able to see, but actually things might be very painful. And we just made to make sure that actually you're all right. And they will, of course, understand that you're going to be really upset and distressed, but they will try to care for you as sensibly as they can to make sure that your body is receiving the treatment that it needs to heal as well. So I know these are really, really difficult conversations, but I just really want to try and de-shame this process. It's not your fault that this happened to you, but
我们听说过“二次创伤”。当法院、警察和整个刑事司法系统实际上可能再次伤害你时，就会发生这种情况。这就是我不想提出指控、不想去警察局的原因之一，还有关于男子气概的问题，因为我不想去警察局。我不想，我也非常害怕被嘲笑，因为社会上存在巨大的神话，认为男性不会被强奸。他们不可能是幸存者，什么都不会发生在他们身上。所以这是我非常害怕的事情。而且，由于情况以及发生在我身上的事情的确切性质，没有物证，这在起诉中是相当令人震惊的。所以有很多不同的因素。但归根结底，这是你的选择。你是唯一真正有权决定是否要提出指控的人。如果你这样做了，那么你很了不起。为你加油。祝你好运。但同样，如果你不这样做，那也没关系。你仍然很了不起。你仍然更强大，因为你活了下来。谢谢你，康纳。处理得非常敏感。
you do deserve for your body to be healed and ultimately for your mind to be able to be healing again too. Yeah, definitely. And one of my favorite quotes from the book was something along at the lines of, it's not your fault because you couldn't have prevented it. And when I read that, I was like, oh wow, that's really true. That's really a powerful. Yeah, powerful, though. And also, like, a building A upon the idea of reporting it was that, thankfully, there are lots more people coming forward to report their sexual violence. And on the news, we tend to see lots of cases, which, thankfully, have been, I found guilty. And as a survivor, I love seeing that. I'm really happy for those of people, because it shows that all of our survivors are really empowered, strong, and we're all just in incredible. But during the worst of my mental health, those news reports also make me cry and a bit de-stressed because I didn't decide to report my assault and my rape to the police. And I know that the vast majority of a people don't either. And I think that it's also good to have a conversation about that because as a survivor, you can also feel really guilty about not reporting it. But it's understandable and like it's okay because also as aspiring society
当然，我会确保相关的帮助热线和零碎信息出现在屏幕上和节目说明中。谢谢你把这个问题带到播客中，并允许我们谈论它。这是一个非常重要的叙事。如果人们在YouTube上观看，我真的希望他们能点赞、评论，如果他们能对这个非常重要的话题表示支持。同样，如果你在Spotify上，你也可以在那里留下评论、问题和答案。再次非常感谢你的时间，康纳。这是一次非常有价值的对话。是的，谢谢你，玛丽安，邀请我，这真的很有趣。我喜欢你的
colleges, we were to hear about secondary traumatisation. It's when the courts, the police and the whole criminal justice system as a whole can actually be traumatise you. So that was one of the reasons why I didn't want to press the charges and I didn't want to go to the police, but also the masculinity point of the because I didn't want to go to the police. I didn't, I was also really scared of being laughed at because of the. the massive societal myths of that men don't get raped. They can't be survivors and nothing
播客。它很棒。谢谢你的分享。哦，谢谢。如果人们想更多地了解你和你的播客，他们该怎么做，康纳？谢谢。我的播客是《心理学世界》（Psychology World），在所有主要的播客应用程序和YouTube上都可以收听。每周一，我们都会涵盖一个全新的心理学主题，无论是临床心理学、认知心理学还是其他领域。如果你想看看我的书，它们也可以在所有主要的电子书零售商处买到。
could ever happen to them. So that's something that I was quite scared about. And also, like, because of the situation and because of the exact nature of what happened to me, there was no physical evidence, evidence though, which is something that's quite appalling in like prosecutions. So there's a lot of different factors. But ultimately, it's your choice. You are the only person who actually has the right to decide. you want to press the charges or not. And if you do, then you are amazing. More power to you. I wish you the best of luck. But equally, if you don't, then that's okay. You're still amazing. You're still stronger because you survived. Thank you, Connor. That was really sensitively handled.
你也可以从当地书店和亚马逊订购。我关于性暴力的书包括《打破沉默》（Breaking the Silence）。这更多是关于肯定，并且很好地建立在今天播客集的基础上。如果你想了解更多关于我的个人旅程和我经历的事情，那么有一本即将出版的书叫《我是幸存者，不是受害者》（I Am a Survivor, Not a Victim）。最后一本是《作为幸存者的疗愈》（Healing as a Survivor），专门关注我的咨询过程以及我在从性暴力中康复时所经历的一切。非常私人的书，但我喜欢它们。好的，很好。我会确保在描述和节目说明中提供这些链接。太棒了。所以人们可以在他们获取播客的任何地方查看
And of course, I will make sure that the relevant help lines and bits and pieces are on screen and in the show notes as well. Thank you for bringing this issue to me in the podcast and for allowing us to talk. about this. It's a really important narrative. I would really love it if people are watching on YouTube, if they can like, if they can comment, if they can show some support to this really important topic. And similarly, if you're on Spotify, you can actually drop in comments and questions and answers there as well. Thank you again so much for your time, Connor. It's a really valuable conversation. Yeah, thank you, like Mavien, I have me, like, it's been like a really fun. I love your
《心理学世界》播客，我相信你也在YouTube上，对吧，康纳？是的。太完美了。谢谢你的时间，祝你未来一切顺利。谢谢你，玛丽安。再见大家。非常感谢我的嘉宾康纳与我们讨论这个非常重要、敏感的话题。我希望你觉得它有帮助。无论你是观看还是收听，你都可以对播客和这一集表示支持。如果你在Apple Podcasts上收听，
podcast. It's a brilliant. Thank you for sharing it. Oh, thank you. And if people want to learn more about you and your podcast, how can they do that, Connor? Then thank you. So my podcast is the PsychologyWy podcast, available on all major podcast apps and YouTube. And every Monday, we cover a brand new site ecology topic, whether it's clinical psychology, cognitive psychology, or a whole other area. And if you want to check out my books, then they're also available on all major ebook retailers.
你可以给节目评分和评论。如果你在Spotify上，你实际上可以留下关于特定集的问题或评论，我总是会回复。YouTube也是一样。我回复我所有的评论。请通过留下评论、支持、点赞、分享、做所有这些好事来表示你的支持，这真的有助于这个频道成长，帮助我们吸引观众，帮助人们知道这是一个可以学习和被倾听的安全地方。
And you can also order them from your local life. and Amazon. And my sexual violence focus books are including breaking the silence. So this is more in affirmation and is a built very nicely on like a today's podcast episode. If you want to hear more about my personal journey and the stuff that I experience, then there's a book coming out called I Am a Survivor, Not a Victim. And then the last one is Healing as a Survivor, which focuses specifically on my accounting sessions and everything that I went through as I healed from sexual violence. Very personal books, but I love them. Okay, good. And I will make sure that there's links to those in the description and show notes as well. Great. So people can check out the
这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Psychology World podcast, wherever they get their podcast, and I believe you're on YouTube as well, aren't you, Connor? Yes. Perfect. Thank you for your time and yeah, wishing you the best with everything in future. Thank you, Maria. Bye everyone. Thank you so much to my guest, Connor, for speaking with us about this really important, sensitive topic. I hope you found it helpful. Whether you are watching or listening, you can show your support to the podcast and to this episode. If you are listening on Apple Podcasts,
Psychology World播客，无论他们在哪里收听播客，我相信你也在YouTube上，对吧，Connor？是的。太好了。谢谢你的时间，祝你未来一切顺利。谢谢你，Maria。再见，各位。非常感谢我的嘉宾Connor与我们讨论这个非常重要且敏感的话题。希望你觉得有帮助。无论你是在观看还是收听，你都可以通过Apple Podcasts来支持本播客和这一集，
you can rate and review the show. If you're on Spotify, you can actually drop comments or questions about the specific episode, and I'll always reply. The same goes for YouTube. I respond to all of my comments. Please do show your support by dropping comments, supporting, liking, sharing, doing all of those good things, which really helps this channel to grow, helps us to attract audiences, helps people to know that this is a safe place to learn and to be heard. to being qualified
你可以为节目评分和评论。如果你在Spotify上，你实际上可以针对特定剧集发表评论或提问，我一定会回复。YouTube也是一样。我会回复我所有的评论。请通过发表评论、支持、点赞、分享以及做所有这些有益的事情来表达你的支持，这真的有助于这个频道的成长，帮助我们吸引观众，帮助人们知道这是一个可以学习和被倾听的安全地方。关于获得资格
is the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是由Marianne Trent博士主持的Aspiring Psychologist播客。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。